hey everyone it's Mike from waterfalls
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
so glad you could join me for today's
video we're going to be talking about
um you know the chop in the market I get
a lot of uh comments
um and saying hey Mike can you make a
video about uh you know how to identify
chop in the order flow and you know how
to deal with it so but before we jump in
if you've been enjoying my videos be
sure to hit the Subscribe button and
click the notification Bell so you don't
miss any new upload and if you find
today's video helpful be sure to hit the
like button for me
and leave a comment uh sharing you know
your biggest takeaway I love hearing
your feedback and you know sometimes you
know from your comments I get ideas to
make videos to show you so your sport
really does go a long way in helping me
create more uh awesome content just like
this so if you're getting value from my
channel and want to see more be sure to
hit the like button subscribe to the
channel and leave a comment alright so
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic all right and you know
chop is one of those things where
um you know a lot of Traders sort of get
uh into trouble so to speak you know on
a trending Market it's one of those
things where you know even if you're a
little bit late you can still make some
decent uh profits but when you run into
an area of chop one the problem is
you're gonna get chopped up hence the
term chop
um you know and Traders are they're
trying to sort of look for some
breakouts to take place they're not
really occurring they're finding
themselves uh getting caught off sides
it's one of those situations equations
where they're buying the high and
selling the low right you want to be
buying the low and selling the high
ideally but uh
in choppy situations right like this
area right down in here it's you know
it's hard Market lacks Direction but
again you know on a nice trending market
like this where it's this was uh
yesterday Friday you know even if you're
a little bit late getting into a trade
you know you could still make some
decent profits but this you know you're
waiting for a breakout That Never Comes
so let's take a look at the order flow
and sort of talk about you know what you
can look for to identify chop taking
place in the market now
this is an order flow related this what
this part I'm going to talk about when
your Market is sort of I don't like to
use the term chop but I I prefer to use
the term sideways activity is you got to
remember right if a market is just made
a big move and again you know we're
selling off from the 45 60 Area 45 you
know 57 all the way down to 45 you know
down to new lows and it bounces a little
bit I mean you can see every time we
sort of hit a low we're struggling to go
higher right here we've got a bit of
sideways activity here this was much
more pronounced but
understanding where areas of sideways
activity can take place is going to give
you a little in my opinion a bit of a
leg up in identifying uh when chop is
taking place at any time you know
whether we have a big move up or a big
move down
and then the market stops
and just it's like looks like maybe it
wants to start to rally and it's it's
not really doing it that could be an
area of uh sideways activity okay until
something gives you another sign that
hey you know what we got another leg in
this move and it continues down or you
know what maybe a lot of buyers are
coming in and the Market's going to
Rally up so
let's take a look at the order flow and
sort of go through some of the signs
that I would look for in identifying a
market that's got sideways activity
um you know some people call it chop I I
just prefer to call market going
sideways and again this is uh you know
the market is selling off quite nicely
quite strongly this was Friday right
they're selling off new lows this red
line new lows new lows new lows we hit
this low here at 1003 now this wasn't
the low of the day yet and then we
proceed to get a little bit of a bounce
okay and it comes off off the low at
seven and three quarters rallies up to
around you know the 14 14 and a half
area okay now
was there any big strong buying taking
place in here well
that there was some nice positive Delta
coming in so there was some aggressive
buying taking place
and then we get up to this bar right up
here okay and this is what I talk about
identifying you know sort of chop
because again remember the market had
just sold off
from you know it was almost a 50-point
move at this point by by 10 o'clock and
what do you think it's going to take
place are people going to take profits
eventually of course they are okay so
this is you know every time I get a
little bit of a bounce off of a low on a
market that's been moving in One
Direction
I'm kind of thinking you know hey is
this profit taking I mean why are we
stopping here you know or are if it's
just profit Taking Chances are we're
going to go sideways right because
people are just taking money off the
table they're putting it in their pocket
it's not
fresh
buying or selling that's coming in yet
right if it's profit taking
and you know sort of what some of the
clues is you know the volume it's kind
of pathetic all right you're just
looking here you know the bar off the
Low 4 000.
three thousand again you know coming
into the lowest six thousand five
thousand seven thousand you see four
thousand three thousand you know four
thousand three thousand three thousand
two thousand two thousand twenty five
ninety seven twenty five hundred twenty
three hundred so you have this move it's
strong selling going down
but we hit the low and we start bouncing
up a little bit
do I think that that's fresh buying
coming in to to sort of say hey you know
what Mike this is the low of the day no
we've got less volume
after we've made that new low so I don't
see like that
fresh buying coming in in the sense of
people that were on the sidelines
thinking hey you know what it's pretty
cheap at this level 45 you know oh eight
oh nine ten
it's just not there so that to me is a
sign of okay maybe this Market is
experience a bounce and if it's
experience a balance it potentially it
could go sideways okay because I'm not
looking for it to Rally again it can
it's low it's gonna do three things it's
going to Rally or it's going to go
sideways or it's going to sell off again
and that weak volume that's taking place
in here is just telling me you know it's
probably going to go sideways and then I
start seeing you know some bearish signs
in the order flow right the bearish
point of control coming in here this is
a slingshot point of control which is a
bearish sign followed by
a bullish Prominent Point of control
here
okay so they're quite close this is at
13 and three quarters this is a ten so
about
um just under four points which to me
you know now I'm seeing the market kind
of getting bracketed this is my
resistance area right here
this is my support area right here what
else do I got I've got another point of
control these are aligned pointed
controls one follows the other and you
got one that sort of marks over here as
well a few bars earlier
then internally I'm looking at these
bars okay yeah I like that I've seen
point of controls go
lower right this is lower than this one
this is lower than the previous one this
is lower than the previous one okay then
it jumps up back down back up back down
a little you know
consecutive aligned point of controls
another align for the controls with that
bullish okay then we rally up where two
here 13. so I'm already seeing the sign
in here of the sideways activity this
was my first sign and I wanted to see if
there was going to be some support
coming in here and you're seeing it with
the point of controls right with the two
consecutive point of controls at the
same price level that sort of lines up
earlier in the middle you've got one two
three four even here one two three
okay so out of one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten bars you got
four at eleven you got three at
eleven and three quarters so it's
telling you just right in here it's
forming you know uh it's kind of
balancing basically okay then you got
another two coming in right here right
anytime I start seeing what it controls
being lined up now you don't have to
wait till way over here this is my clue
that hey you know what if we're going to
sell off I got my bearish sign here
right this is the low down here I want
to see it but it's just starting to go
bounce back and forth right you're
seeing the point of controls one two
three one two three then you got that
bullish one so I'm looking for this
Market to sort of go back and forth now
it does pop back up again it comes back
up to this resistance level two more
pointed controls at that level goes back
up then it comes right back in here
okay again is this a sign of a potential
breakout right because we just sort of
took out this little swing High here
earlier well okay let's see maybe maybe
not
um you know the order flow is kind of
bullish right three imbalances nice
bullish
Delta then a nothing Delta and a strong
Delta then it comes right back with
selling
strong buying strong selling more strong
selling energy back where you started
okay again every time it looks like it's
about to break out
you're not getting that sort of
strong
buying coming in I mean you get the one
bar with nice positive Delta then a bar
with small Delta then another bar with
nice positive Delta what you want to see
is sort of that continued positive Delta
right 492
and then just 39 if this was 390 I'd be
more excited about it just like back
here strong Delta small Delta strong
Delta then negative Delta strong Delta
strong negative Delta right it's not
being consistent
okay then it's just sort of Bounce
Around bounce around just sort of going
sideways now we've sort of found this
newer level a bit higher right from you
know you could even take it from this
high but really you're gonna be looking
right around here and again you're
seeing all the point of controls more or
less right back in that same level now
these are a bit more scattered okay but
you're seeing it start to line up one
two anytime I see basically two pointed
controls
at the same price level consecutively
it could either be a sign of a market
that is consolidating going sideways
or you know a market that's just
balancing basically and then you see one
two here these you go with three going
down right from lower lower lower than
up up
but they're around the same level here
and here right and then you get in here
even though these are kind of mixed here
you could sort of average these together
just visually looking at it and you know
almost draw that line at 16 and a
quarter these would all match up
right obviously one two three
these two are right around the same
level these two right around the same
level because why is that important is
because
this is a one minute chart
and it's spending time
over the same price you know let's say
over the same price but rather
it's facilitating
a lot of volume right Point control is
the most volume in a bar
over time
okay
and you can just see you know pair up
pair up pair up almost a pair up almost
a pair up then it starts dripping down
here a little bit lower lower lower
lower but again it's just one price
level lower here and here
okay and then you know finally when it
starts to break out now you're sort of
gapping all right you're getting more
you're not seeing the pairs up pair UPS
here at this point once it sort of gets
below this this 14 area stays below
there okay then it opens the door now
it's one thing to look at the point of
controls that makes it you know a bit
easier a bit clearer
but
what I found
that helps me out a lot that's why we've
added it into our order flows Trader
software
is the value areas
okay and again the value area right I
use 70 value area in percent
you know the value area is where 70 of
the volume of the bar trades okay and
I'll just turn it on here
and what I'm looking for at the value
areas is overlapping value because when
a market is trending right value areas
tend to be going in a direction okay but
when I see value areas basically
overlapping you know one two three four
five six seven eight bars overlapping
that is a sign of a market that is
basically going sideways but you got
earlier sign right here this one one two
three four five six bars already
overlapping here
okay then it'll Gap up so the higher the
value is higher than one two three four
then eight another three another three
looks like it's going to go up
well you got this Gap up here it doesn't
build off it get back down then one two
three four overlapping
one two three overlapping
um you know basically my I like to look
at periods of three or more
one two three four
and again one two three one two three
four five six seven uh six one two three
four five six seven okay so again you
just had that by by one tick then it
just overlaps everything else again
right around the same levels
so you know that's why I use value areas
because to me it's it's pretty clear
when a market is
balancing when I see value areas
overlapping one two three four five six
okay now what I like to see if if I'm
thinking a market is going to start
moving there's some gaps in the value
the bigger the better you know this one
is from 15 and three quarters up to 60
and three quarters so four ticks you
know almost a point which is nice
kind of expecting to move higher it just
came in here then it starts coming back
down and overlapping one two three four
five six again
okay there's a gap in here
one pick Gap then another one two three
Gap
Gap Gap so once it starts gapping
consecutively or you know in a series
to me that's a sign of a market that's
potentially starting to move in a
direction right so you got one Gap two
gaps three gaps right this one value
area low of this bar equals the value
area high of this bar
all right then it overlaps another Gap
here another Gap here
so you know I I like to watch those
little bits that movement right in value
is value moving higher or moving lower
and how is it doing it
is it putting some space in Between the
Bars or not you know those are just sort
of the little things that I like to look
at in determining you know hey is the
market going sideways you know one of
the other things I like to look for
on a market that's going sideways is you
know I'll watch the Deltas
right if I see a big Delta like here 785
I'm looking for the market to build off
of it here he had 662.
523 539 662 okay hey you know what some
strong buying is coming in let's build
off of it then 269 okay it's a little
bit weaker but still decent 437 okay
that's great then minus 161 minus 140.
it's not building anymore negative
negative negative big positive
let's go
Delta one
and a Delta of 295 okay maybe it's
picking up again Delta 57 Delta 56.
smaller than a negative Delta minus 351
then you know 167 and then strong again
a 456 hey you know what maybe it's gone
then 147.
155. this is what it looked like maybe
it was going to take off 767 Delta then
just 89 but then 774. hey that's great
and then boom
minus 400. hey 600 this is it ah oh
sorry false start minus 300 minus 592.
right back into our sideways area in
here so again you know what I look at is
I look at Deltas I look at Point
controls I look at the value areas and
determining
um you know if a market is going
sideways all right so I hope that helps
some of you guys you know it's one of
those things it takes a bit of
experience to understand Honestly by by
watching the markets for a while and
just sort of watching how it goes you
know watch anytime there's a big move
right markets don't move in a straight
line they move they stop and oftentimes
they go stop and go sideways Okay so
um think about it think of it like an
elevator right you get an elevator
foreign people get in all right you're
going up to the 32nd Floor but it stops
at 18. some people get in some people
get out
then it goes to 21.
some people get in some people get out
right and the Market's the same way it
goes up it goes down it stops at certain
levels people get in people get out sort
of look for those signs right if
when the elevator is going to continue
but you know when you sort of see mixed
things in the order flow that's a sign
of a market that's going to be going
sideways so all right guys that wraps up
this video on on Sideways activity I
hope uh some of you guys at least found
these tips helpful I'm sure people say
hi Mike you're you're on crack or
something this doesn't make sense but
you know honestly when you start to look
at the markets
it's one thing to look here you know on
a Saturday Sunday Saturday afternoon
Saturday evening
and go through it but you got to process
it in real time
um and you know that's why I make these
videos so people say why don't you show
live trading well I'm showing you know
you go to school right you learn you
know you don't
you go to medical school
early on you don't dissect real live
people
um you know and same thing you know I'm
giving you the ideas that you got to
take and when you're watching the market
look for these things all right so
if you've enjoyed this video be sure to
hit that like button subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss any of my
upcoming videos and again you'll be sure
to leave some comments down there let me
know what you think thanks for watching
and being a part of my order flow
Community I'll see you guys on the next
video bye-bye